[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance and kissing
and this is the show for you if you're
bored of watching people argue on the
internet about subjects they know
nothing about a trigonometry we don't
pretend to be the experts we ask the
experts
our fantastic expert guests this week is
the editor-in-chief of arrow magazine
helen pluck rose
welcome to trigonometry thank you for
having me it's great that you're here
thank you so much for coming and listen
before we get into the Q itself tell our
viewers and our listeners a little bit
about who you are how are you where you
are well I'm I'm here from here in East
London and my background is in English
literature and studies but I came into
the kind of the culture was kind of via
the new atheist movement I've always
been very concerned about epidemiology
how we know what is true and about
liberal ethics so I was very critical of
religion and making unfounded truth
claims and having all kinds of liberal
ideas about swimming and LGBTQ so that
was the same ferment for Peter and James
who did so we'll get on to that so from
that when I was studying English
literature and tried to look at women's
history then the whole problem of
post-modernism in theory that's divided
from post-modernism just kept coming up
and getting in the way of looking at
anything rigorously
and and ethically so I gradually my
attention has turned from religious
truth claims and human rights issues to
to to ones rooted in in theory and in
activism and that's sort of currently
most known as social justice approach
well we'll get into all of that and the
post
in the second but tell us a little about
area of the magazine first of all for
anyone who's not familiar with it
yeah area was set up by Yamaha Mali to
try and cut through the partisan divides
to try and be open to a great range of
ideas which were based on evidence and
reason and and try and get the other
different conversations out there and
get people together he moved on in June
and I have taken it over and I'm staying
true to his aim and I'm trying to get it
a bit more well known in the UK at the
moment half of our readers are in the
u.s. what does it mean to be a liberal
because I hear this word bandied about a
lot of people talk about being a liberal
a lot of the time sometimes people who
say they're liberal I hear them speaking
I go oh that doesn't sound very liberal
to me so what does it mean to you to be
a liberal well I think what you just
said they're sort of curves if that
doesn't seem very liberal if something
is a liberal we recognize it much more
easily it's something which isn't fair
which isn't it's free so to be a liberal
is to is to try to shut down certain
freedoms it's to be unbalanced and and
and I'm just really so when we are so
liberal in this broadest sense what we
are looking at is people who are
concerned with freedom of speech freedom
of belief freedom of choice generally
and people who are interested in in a
fair society and giving everybody the
same opportunities to achieve everything
it's a focus on individuality and shared
humanity so every individual gets to
access everything our shared society
offers so coming back to my facebook
echo chamber bombing comedy a
frighteningly hard left industry and a
lot of people tell me that freedom of
speech is a right
we issue and therefore nothing to do a
liberalism do you agree no I mean that
that's what the the problem that we're
seeing at the moment there the Liberals
went when that the word liberal first
came about it was about freedom from the
state in Italy in France and it's still
I say it still does it still should be
about about about this overarching
freedom but what we've seen that happen
is that beautiful scene has kind of
shifted so that now we have this hard
left coming up and it's it comes from
somewhere completely different to be
wholly blame it comes from the radical
side of what was once the the Marxist
side that's it's a rejection of Marxism
but it keeps this kind of idea of that
it's really quite sort of them
authoritarian idea of language creating
reality so we have to be very careful
with language we have to monitor and
regulate what people can say and what
they can't say because that constructs
our social reality which is in stark
contrast to the traditional liberal idea
of the marketplace of ideas where we
believe that we can beat bad ideas with
better ones and things that is in fact
what we have done with increasing
rapidity throughout sort of the last
century
so yeah the the freedom of speech is not
always now associated with the Liberals
if we're associating liberals with the
left but the hard left is a liberal so
we can get lost in the words that
because of course in in America liberal
is understood often to be synonymous
with the left and in Australia it's
understood to be synonymous with the
right so I think we just have to be
saying what we're talking about the
opposite available it must be quite
complicated for someone like years old
because when we were talking about you
coming onto the show you mentioned that
you're someone who comes from the left
right yeah so it must be quite weird to
see that part of of
of the political spectrum be kind of
cannibalized by this hard element
increasingly and to the point where as
you say we don't know what a you know
what's a left-liberal you know it's
become very complicated doesn't it yes
what I'm very pleased to see is that a
lot of the identitarian social justice
identity politics left are increasingly
rejecting
and they are associating it as they're
rejecting it they're associating it with
freedom focus on freedom of speech and a
focus on a level playing field and not
noticing race not finding it significant
race gender sexuality and they see that
as a problem it's trying to maintain the
status quo which is unjust so there will
be a lot of criticism from them of
liberals which actually helps our cause
quite a lot for those on the right who
in employment and sort of complaint
identity so they're kind of pushing out
almost the the people who are liberal as
you say yeah and essentially because
look we're equally critical and the show
of people on the far right and as the
far left I think they're both very very
dangerous and that's why they have to be
they have we have to counter them as you
say with better ideas right
yeah and I'm more worried about the far
right and the populist right but I I
think that is why it's so important to
address the problems on the left because
when we're in the situation where people
who are not yet firmly committed to left
or right but there's somewhere little
tried to see who is making more sense
there's a real problem if the nest isn't
making sense if the right is seeming
more reasonable
what coherent than the left then that's
something that we leftist need to need
to address we can't just say well
everybody who's gone right has suddenly
become racist sexist homophobic and not
carrying that for people something that
has happened to undermine calm
in the left and we need to address that
as much as we need to criticize the
right and why are you worried about
right-wing populism in the right of
rocking the rise of right-wing populism
because it's anti expertise its aunty
knowledge it's producing quite a lot of
the same problems that that
post-modernism is where we have
alternative ways of knowing they have
alternative facts we have posters and
they have post truth so we've seen a lot
of the same sorts of very very fluffy
thinking but then you get a little
better a real sort of problem with
expertise generally reactions to some of
our work from people sort of populist
right is yeah experts nothing
universities teaching I think we just
need to sort of go with common sense and
local knowledge and tradition because if
you think you know we are the most
advanced we've ever been technologies
and most advanced has ever been yet you
get these people now who sort of reject
all that what why do you know if they do
you think it's down to the fact that
they feel betrayed
I think there's come about a certain
complacency and I think that what has
happened is that society culturally has
been a liberal left for so long there's
a really liberal ideas elite they're
sort of left sort of economic social
ideas have really been dominating as
what is good that people have forgotten
how to actually defend them and argue
for them it just seems like this is how
it should be so when one side becomes to
culturally powerful it can kind of turn
in on itself stop nasal gazing and I
really get quite mad so what we've seen
with the cultural dominance and with the
rise of the postmodern ideas which came
in at the the end of the
listen rights movement something all
that good stuff with them you know equal
pay for women and equal rights for
people are already seasoned in
criminalizing homosexuality yeah this
has come in on the end of that and it's
it's a completely different mad way of
looking at it so now we've got that
happening on the left and on the right
we've got a kind of reactionary pushback
where there's a kind of pre-modern lost
Alger for a time that that never was but
you know when there was just traditional
marriage and traditional gender roles
and so we've got that narrative kind of
coming in from there there's a deep
suspicion which is not unjustified of
the idea of liberal elites in
universities talking incomprehensibly
about pronouns and things so there's
that but there's the too much of a
reaction to that you know that there's a
lot of wanted to throw babies that we've
bass-drum that I think if we did lose
our our senses of knowledge production
people would appreciate them there is a
lot of people I think there are a lot of
people who feel like as you say
universities and the media and politics
has been dominated by a certain way of
thinking for so long the the push back
now is almost a necessary correction to
some extent but as you say you can't
throw away the baby with the bathwater
so how do we move forward from how do we
create which is what we're trying to do
on the show is create that same center
within which people from the left people
from the kind of non far right can come
together and go actually we're all same
people we're all trying to move to the
same place oh no this is a good facebook
update you say something our racism
spared yeah well other than complicated
in the articulate solution
I think James Lindsay and I we wrote a
manifesto against the enemies of
modernity events didn't need to mock
achieve title and what we appointed
outage is similar to what you've just
said is that the lunatics are the
triggers they they are the extremes but
what we are doing too much
when we lean one way or the other is
looking at the extremes on the other
side reacting against that condoning or
minimizing the problems on our outside
and getting sort of further and further
polarized we think that we need to read
reconceptualize this and look at how
many of us actually value the fruits of
modernity we value science we value
reason based philosophy strong
institutions the liberal sense of
freedom and of equal opportunity we are
the majority and if we are pushing back
at the far right or the far left rather
than at people who counter these values
which are very sort of essential to the
development civilization then we are
having what we are aiming at the wrong
things we're going to be fighting with
people that we don't really need to be
fighting with and we're not going to be
addressing the problems that we should
be addressing and I think it's
particularly important to address the
ones that are on your own side because
if I know that I share very similar aims
to the social justice left I'm
particularly concerned about social
equality
I am I'm interested in in culture and in
groups within culture and whether they
are all having equal access to
everything so we have the same aims but
we have very different approaches so
what we need to do on this is talk about
our approaches there's a certain
resistance to talking or being allowed
to say anything from that group so that
makes it hard but we need to we need to
address it and I think people on the
rights as well need to be looking at
their extreme
because there's a tendency there to say
yes look we have a few neo-nazi marches
to which like 12 people turn up and
everybody else knows that they're
they're bad people with that's not that
how it defines us meanwhile you've got
all these institutions which are really
quite sort of controlled by this
narrative which which makes no sense so
we're not worried about our looms well
you should be because we are seeing
something of a resurgence of racism of
sexism homophobia because we're seeing a
bit of a push back to traditional groups
there's an idea that there's a there's a
threat because I'm not don't say that
the left began it's it's been going back
and forth for a long time in America the
extremes of the right to produce the
left items think here that the extremes
of the Left have produced the pushback
from the right I think we've got this
sort of coming up when we've got this
reaction now where we have you know it
becomes socially acceptable for women to
make rigid negative generalizations
about men for ethnic and racial
minorities to being disparaging it's
also quite toxic masculinity
yeah and white for doing all this kind
of stuff we what we're seeing from that
is a kind of pushback reaction because
even if we accept that systems of power
exists in which some groups have been
disadvantaged and may now be angry and
they want to say things and that we
should understand if we even if we
accept that we've got this kind of
hardwired sense of fairness and
reciprocity in us so if there is this
seeming imbalance where it's okay to be
racist and sexist sometimes that does
tend to produce a corresponding racism
of sex
and so I think that goes a long way to
explain why we are now hearing more sort
of openly sexist or racist comments
which which are which are kind of
reactive so yeah I think we need to also
focus on well you talked about the need
for conversations on your own site and
as you say you're coming from the left
one of the things that you've been
involved with you you mentioned earlier
with Peter and James recently is
precisely enough to do that yeah which
is you why don't you tell everybody who
a lot of people who are watching the
show will know exactly what we're
talking about vote for anyone who
doesn't know about this whole for fake
papers and the grievant Studies thing
tell us a little bit about what happened
what did you do why did you do it and
what was the result yeah we spent a year
we intended to spend up to two years but
we got called what we wanted to write
some papers that you may know James and
Peter wrote a paper before in which they
claimed that penises are best understood
as concepts it was very very funny but
they submitted it to a journal which was
quite about rights and there was some
debate of the whether it was predatory
and whether redaction had actually shown
that these ideas were acceptable or that
journals won't publish anything if
there's a sort of profit for them so
they decided to take a lot of the good
criticisms from the last thing and spend
a year or two writing
much sort of papers which looked at what
we are all worried about looked at a
demand of objective knowledge this sort
of whole idea that culture is a that
everything is culturally constructed and
this inconsistent sort of liberalism
where we're doing everything in terms
systems of power and certain groups who
are always marking lized certainly ones
who are always privileged what can and
can't be said all of those big sort of
things that that we're seeing in action
in social justice movements and which
are coming from papers in feminist
critical race this technology philosophy
so we decided and they brought me in on
this to write as many papers as we could
and get them into the top journals in
those sub disciplines so we we've got
one in feminist geography now that's not
the highest in geography but it's the
top in feminist geography when we're at
researching these ideas we're finding
that a lot of them that have great sort
of cultural power like are coming from a
collection of a few of the same journals
so we started targeting them with ideas
which just should have been very clearly
nonsense not on evidence and also
unethical so yeah we claim that by
examining the genitals of the thousand
dogs on an Argand dog park we could see
evidence of human rape culture and some
tips on how to train men like dogs that
we shouldn't have been acceptable and
yeah but we've we did to get a section
of mine comes which was rewritten as
intersectional feminism and it's
important not to as well too much that
we're not that you know it's not
sections talking about genocide or if it
but it's that very sort of totalitarian
grievance since the
and them and they're needing to have
everybody to such as yet become one
solid group against the enemy so we yeah
we managed to get back through we found
that that morbid obesity is not admired
in the same way that muscular bodies are
because of prejudice and that they
should be that there should be but a
bodybuilding competition should include
bodies that are built with muscle that's
quite a good premise for a job yeah it
is American from 1901 comedian who
tweets about that all the time a serious
problem we have seen you know campaigns
to to prevent their cancer research from
saying obesity isn't it's a problem
doctors talking about it it's it's the
medical as a medical issue I'll accuse
their fat shaming and you know I as
someone who doesn't exactly have been
privileged I still kind of see that this
is a problem wait we can't this is a big
sort of health problem this is an
epidemic and we need to actually address
it as a health condition so but I'm
quite concerned about in fact that
activist kidding how much do you think
and maybe this is me and my brutally
uneducated mind when I see these people
talk about factors and all the rest of
it how much of it is just victim culture
and just unwillingness to accept
responsibility
I think that's being I mean there is
this thing where it's good to take on a
victim identity now yeah so if you can
claim to have marginalized identity then
you have a certain status within these
communities so there there certainly is
that there are there are helpful ways
null helpful ways to look at things like
like obesity and mental illness and the
unhelpful things do is to take it on
and not allow it to be seen as a problem
because that would be prejudice so that
I think I worry particularly about that
I think that those kind of problems need
to be recognized as a health condition
which you know B people don't don't you
not be bullied certainly and you know
people we've met a little it's the art
but the idea is should still always be
to get better to fix the problem or
improve the problem so I am worried that
this is it's tying into into the whole
sort of marginalized identity thing that
I think as well that we're seeing that
in the realms of trans activism because
trans people exist there is a growing
amount of science which shows us why
some people feel that they are the
opposite sex to what their genitals tell
them they are and yet we are seeing
particularly among teenagers a growing
tendency to identify as non-binary or
demi something which seems to have an
element of a cultural ideological factor
as well which then makes it quite
difficult to identify who is trans judge
who is trans and who isn't this is what
people know themselves but yeah we are
seeing an increasing ideological basis
for complicating gender identity in
addition to what is real which is the
existence of trans people so that is
likely to damage the trans of course
considerably because in 10 or 20 years
the statistics which now show that
people who identify as trans after
puberty and normally do so for the rest
of their lives and then looking at the
brains
post-mortems yeah evidence why it's
found but what we're likely to find now
is load of people in their thirties
identifying as trends and then stop
resisting and this is gonna undermine
the I may disappoint you make about
young people because famously you know
to be near teenagers at time of
exploration you don't know really who
you are you don't know what you know
your sexuality is a lot of the time it's
a time of expiration you write things up
you find out who you are you find out
where your boundaries are on if you're
going to you know say that somebody is
trans at such an early age I mean it's
it's a recipe for disaster
it takes on ideological components I
mean otherwise with people I'm sure
they're very sure that it's not the same
as their genitals and there are sensible
national ways to to go about supporting
me working out and that's what your your
papers that you you wrote with two guys
that's what you were trying to show is
that some of these academic subjects
which inform our discourse to a very
significant extent I would argue they
are purely ideological and there is no
pursuit of truth of fact in that subject
so you publish these papers you try and
get them through the magnet through the
academic journals you're successful with
some of them yeah we it's fine we had to
stop we had seven in there were three
more we were very confident we're going
in this section of mine
yes so yeah we were confident of getting
10 weird there are another two that we
probably getting but yes it being so
yeah and they do make me particularly
the ones that looked at feminist
epidemiology which is something I'm
particularly interested in that argues
very explicitly that we shouldn't have a
Western philosophical tradition which
goes along with slavery and this one
construction of knowledge needs to be
given a backseat selection these other
knowledge is coming and have their say
and this is obviously based very much on
the idea that knowledge is is
constructed and it's constructed by your
position in society so there will be a
black and a legion of winning the legion
trans knowledge and these will be
different to straight white men's
knowledge which unfortunately it's being
associated with science and reason and
see how our racist and sexist it is to
associate straight men straight white
men are the ones who do science logic
and reason yes my girlfriend's good
she's doing a doctor at the moment in
psychology I want to point out here
we're having a stem crisis we are
reliant on attracting scientists doctors
and engineers from India Pakistan
Nigeria you wonder what they think if
they arrived to be told that they that
this is a a white masculinist
imperialist type of knowledge and they
should really be using traditional than
healing practices in one sense it must
have been quite exciting you know you
were sort of exposing the flaws in the
system
was actually quite dispiriting and
depressing there was a sort of heavy
mixture of yeah because I mean we knew
what we were going to find we were
fairly sure that we were going to come
across this we're going to be encouraged
to be less than rigorous there was going
to be ideological pressure but when in
theory yet we had to do a lot of
research people sometimes they're
claiming that we just may put another
job in in things no we didn't we read
the papers we understand the theory we
we get the concepts and we developed
them in horrible ways so that does kind
of take a toll on you as well I
personally I had a big burst of reading
critical race epidemiology and Jose
Medina and Barbara Applebaum in
particular being white being good white
complicity and I I sort of read both of
those books in the same day and then in
the evening I was just watching a TV
show in which a mixed-race student was
graduating and she helped her her white
mother and I don't know she lost her
mother even though she's white myself
but this has gone into my head from
having read this I'm looking at this I
I'm seeing relationships in terms of
balances of power and it's yes it
started to me thinking more how is it
when there are young people in
universities and then perhaps they are a
mixed race whatever are they having to
sort of evaluate their their family
structures in terms of oppressors and
the oppressed and recently after that
there was some big notice government
work was I think it was at a university
which asked students of color not to
bring their white relatives to things
because it was threatening to other
people and just the division
here that it's it's just not a way I
mean even with America which has this
very recent very awful racial divide and
that an oppressive system is this the
way to heal it I don't think it is
we were talking beforehand about the
about ridiculous examples of this kind
that you know these kind of trends of
thought or schools of thought there was
one about glaciers that you mentioned in
the feminist geography I mean I'm not
the brightest bronc in the world
geography be feminist yeah yeah the
feminist glaciology paper was yeah very
well known that that was because it was
just so ridiculous you have to look at
ice through a feminist lens and there
there was some part of it in which there
was phone being attached iglesias that
there was some kind of communication
going on and it was it was crazy and
James read that one thoroughly and he
based his feminist astronomy and the
paper on that and that's argued that
astronomy needs to take in astrology and
not only astrology but feminist and
queer astrology absolutely so this is
the only way to study the Stars and like
all the best planets have male names
right go to Venus Jupiter Mars you know
the best pranks are going come on why
did you stop being produced but that one
hadn't got in by the time we had to stop
but it was one of those who are
confident about and they actually don't
seem to have noticed what's happened
because they're still writing to us
asking us to hurry up and realize it and
get it back to them because in that one
the comments that that we got were that
this is very exciting that these sort of
ideas have made some impact in
psychology and biology but they're not
into the really hard sciences yet and it
would be wonderful to see feminist
approaches in physics classes and things
oh god yeah that one really did affect
James quite badly Heath's and we called
him the supercomputer because he's got
this incredibly sort of logical mind so
he read the feminist glaciology paper
through and carefully and then he just
sort of didn't speak for three days so
traumatized by the way humans are
thinking that's just completely
irrational and when you attach the font
to the guy she did he talk back
how many member what what the plan of
that was but I'm just oh we're talking
about this this is feminists apparently
I'm thinking of all the the years and
we've tried to overcome this idea that
women are too Simeon frivolous to do
science and now you're let's put the
telephone equation you can talk to it's
not even back to because they've all
been on a cuz I never get any signals
that I've been it but did you get a lot
of a backlash the you know people came
out and going up what you're doing you
are you know you were part of the
oppression and you were part of you know
the the white hierarchy looking to
oppress us and all the rest of it yes
there's been a lot of that this has been
made yet from the extreme activists type
and then things have happened following
and we've been linked in to them only
yesterday I was I was told it was
assumed that I was celebrating the
murder of twelve Jews because I'm quite
clearly a fascist so yeah and the
changes from the Trump administration
is planning fur and that with just sort
of pretend trans people didn't exist I
apparently and responsible for that I
was told so that there has been a lot of
that it has been you are just trying to
perpetuate your privilege and this is
what our paper when the joke's on you
was about we anticipated this response
and we wrote a paper going deep into
feminist status team ology and that's
stacking up a load of things to argue
that there just isn't any way at all not
even in-depth academic hoaxes we said
which was a bit of a risk that would
show that people had engaged well enough
with the ideas to criticize and disagree
with them and that that is what we've we
found real it's this idea of them ever
privilege preserving epistemic pushback
and what that means is that any
criticism of social justice approaches
is just an attempt to preserve privilege
it shouldn't be engaged with as an
argument it just takes away from the
important issues it needs to be shut
down and that's particularly horrified
me and so that that was why we went into
that paper to try and work out where
this argument is coming from and that
one was the yes we want it within eight
days which is very very fast and yeah
every vision and
it's the fastest one and they called it
an excellent contribution to feminist
philosophy
well this tactic that you talked about
it is incredibly effective which I
suspect the way through the social
justice just as people use it which is
to they've come up with a way of not
having to engage with people's ideas
because frankly a lot of their ideas
don't stand up to actual logic and all
other white male you know oppressive
behavior like analyzing what they're
saying when you look at it it doesn't
stand up to scrutiny so they've come up
with a great fantastically effective way
of countering that problem which is you
go
well you're white therefore you don't
know what you're talking about or you're
this you don't know we're talking or
you're a man and therefore you can't
talk about this because you can't know
you can't have that woman's knowing yeah
welcome to stretch out as much as you
can this in this craft and tiny studio
feel free to so so what I'm what I'm
saying is they've come up with a very
effective way of countering logic and
reason and research and argument and is
that not why they keep coming back what
this is because it's really effective
there's a chicken and egg thing going on
I mean what the way that you've just
said it so it sounds quite quite cynical
we want to get our views across
therefore we're going to reject evidence
and reason but in fact the rejection of
evidence and reasoning came first and
the whole system is sort of built on
that with it with the sort of starts of
post-modernism the idea was that
knowledge is not to be found it is to be
made and so everything is a constructor
in the categories that we have produced
so this idea that how we see knowledge
now is a construct of an imperialist
patriarchal age is truly believed so
people like Allison Woolf
for example in in her paper which we
draw on a lot
tell me how that makes you feel will
argue specifically that this reason
emotion divided it's not a proper
philosophical context you cannot say in
the philosophy class you haven't given
any evidence some reason for that so I'm
not going to believe you because that is
to perpetuate a Western philosophical
tradition and we need to give emotional
and experiential knowledge the same
amount of credits so that that's very
very central to feminist and critical
race epidemiology and yes it does also
have the effect of very simply shutting
down any objection because it is unless
you agreed with me then you're just not
able to see things from my perspective
because your privilege is blinding you
there's there's nothing that can be done
with that so that was really why we
wanted to write that particular essay
and go really into that to saying yes we
do understand it we do know how it works
we've engaged with social justice
concepts of knowledge we still disagree
but yeah there are responses we've got
to that is yeah this is just because
you're you're white and the other two
male
do you think there is some truth to this
I mean this is something I've been
thinking about in order to try and
understand where these people might be
coming from is do you think there is
some truth to the idea that over a
period of time we focused a little bit
too much on facts and logic and we have
ignored people's what they call lived
experiences that do inform us like you
know if I was to tell you I'm from
Russia right if we were talking about
Russia if I was to say well when I was
growing up a Russia blah blah blah
happened that would have some value to
an analysis of what's happening in
Russia wouldn't it do you think that the
reason that this has happened is that
maybe we've been ignoring that a little
bit I'm not sure I'm not sure that we
ever have there has always been there's
certainly been an emphasis on some
science and reason and there's been
certain skeptic organizations which have
been very scathing at that personal
anecdotes or experiences are ever
relevant and that can certainly sort of
shut down a conversation because as
humans we do have the experience isn't
often somebody's the experience is more
importance of what we're talking about
the example of this that I give is is if
mother has lost her child there are
facts about how this child has died
perhaps the medical community are
interested in these facts what is of
interest to the people who love the
family and about how this is affecting
her how she feels so we as humans are
often much more focused on how everybody
is feeling and experiencing things than
we are on what is true and that is why
we tend to do so badly on examining what
is true and finding out what is true and
tending to trust their own feelings and
biases to a huge extent so I certainly
don't think that there is any problem
with scholarship which is looking at
experiences with social justice
movements in
which care about how things make people
feel I myself studied the Christian
narrative in late sort of many evil
times and how this this was you that
this is this is on the importance to
humans but what we need not to do is
claim that personal experience is the
same thing as knowledge or objective
truth we have to keep knowledge and
truth are separate from perspective and
experience but we can vary both well the
reason I bring this up Seraph I just
want to finish the point is if we were
sitting not in 2018 but in say 1930s
Germany or before that in America during
the time where people scientifically
believed that black people are inferior
right it could be reasonably argued
there has there have been periods in
time where power determined what truth
is including scientific truth hmm right
so and that is an argument that social
justice people make which is that who
has power and society determines what
the science tells us to some extent
right do you buy into that argument at
all I certainly accept that that there
have been times when science has has
supported racist and sexist ideas but
what we have to look at is that parrot
systems of power have always supported
racist energy religious sort of tribal
loyalties and the ideas of
rigid gender roles this has been fairly
constant it is significant that it was
in the age where of science and reason
and evidence that we overcame that
because you can't do science for very
long and not fix a whole load of bad
assumptions that you have about race and
gender the evidence is there that men
and women have equal intelligence
there's greater variability in male but
there are the
intelligence that we have equal ability
to perform all types of tasks although
we mean I'm not likely to have slightly
different interests to men so whereas
before when we have say the Christian
narrative but I looked at where men are
guided by sapiens yet the mind and
women's skills here
that's guarantee at the body of the
senses wear them wear em yeah that you
can't really argue with that because God
said it it's not hypothesis that men are
naturally more intelligent than women
and men need to be more Boeing is made
in a scientific context science is going
to show that not to be true and that is
what we have seen happen so when people
are saying I am a supporter of science
they're not saying I support anything
but science once agreed with we're
talking about supporting a system a
self-correcting system which has been
more effective at weeding out human
biases and having watching the left
slowly descend into insanity and
especially what you're talking about
well it's almost beyond parody now you
can't really parody it because it is
where it is more they you didn't Perry
in a way you just gave them what they
wanted in a sense but well see what's
happened to the left do you think that
just gives greater strength to them to
the right and you know the alright when
they go when people you know have put up
legitimate criticisms if they walk by
and go you know whatever it may be and
all they have to do is go well look at
the lift I mean that is that is what my
primary concern is because I'm
unapologetic about wanting to forget the
left part is it I but I want the neck to
be electable again and I do think and we
have argued over and over
that much of the search of the right to
the right is a reaction to the behavior
on the left we I mean the if we're
looking at people who voted Obama last
time and then went to Trump these are
two very very different men do we think
about the voters once held Obama views
and now hold Trump his views that is not
very likely something has drawn them to
the right and push them from the left as
much as we're looking at what has drawn
them to the right and a lot of things I
keep going back to America because this
is where I've focused a lot recently
a lot of this was fear of immigration
means that he's Trump's most popular
policy still remains the muslimeen ban
whether or not we think that's the
correct term for it which is very
worrying but then the second motivation
that is that is often cited is the fear
of identity politics are wanting to
punish liberals for furn of this sort of
highly politicized identity thing for
not prioritizing the working class which
was essentially seen as their job so I
think that we're seeing
yes we're seeing a mixture of things but
I was so it's been so close on things
like Trump and on brexit that we really
need there's not huge amounts of
improvement that needs to be made to
kind of shift the tide back because when
I see the live talking about all these
things I want why aren't you talking
about the fact that wages haven't risen
in however no why are we not talking
about the fact that the gap between rich
and poor and getting ever wider why are
we not talking about about the fact that
their health service doesn't seem to be
functioning properly all these really
important issues which then that should
be dealing with which as a person on the
left I'm passionate about instead we're
talking about icebergs now they have a
[ __ ] vagina or not
yeah what's going on Helen didn't expect
these yeah this is the criticism made by
the old left that the socialist left
we've had a lot of support from the
their socialist because they argue but
it that the whole sort of postmodern
identitarian movement has just taken the
left away from the working class and
moved it into the universities and
rented it incomprehensible and they say
with which were probably right that a
lot of the reason that the class issues
aren't being targeted now is because
it's that these ideas are coming from
people who are really in the top weighed
racket we're looking at professors and
and academics you know that they're not
hugely huge player but they are well
paid so there is a less of a concern on
working-class issues and on class issues
and unless it is blended with some other
kind of identity so having to admit that
working-class white men and face any
disadvantages in society really screws
up that's that's really sort of
downplayed and this is why I get quite
frustrated with people who try to
confuse post-modernism with Marxism and
with what we're seeing at the moment is
an evolution of postmodern ideas into
identity studies in the late 80s early
90s a number of theories so kimberlé
crenshaw and judith butler and then
post-colonial they they took these ideas
and they said what we need to keep the
whole cultural constructivist bit but we
can't just dismantle everything because
we need to look at society so what we're
going to say is that there are certain
groups in certain places experiencing
certain disadvantages which the original
post modernist ideas did not and
and so French or particularly the
founder intersectionality and sort of
influential in critical race theory
describes intersectionality as
contemporary politics applied to
postmodern theory so we're looking very
much at this kind of system so if it
gets conflated with Marxism which is
what post-modernism was very critical of
and reacted against because for Marxist
there's an objective truth there's an
overarching structure then we are not
going to be addressing the problem in
the right way we're going to be
confusing class analysis which just
almost is not present at all with am
identitarian focus on constructive
knowledge and it makes it much harder to
deal with and I think what's happening
with this conflation is sometimes it's a
cynical thing it allows right-wingers to
link their two enemies the economic left
and the identitarian left and just
dismiss them while pointing at communist
regimes and do legs so that's very easy
and neat but also the postmodern ideas
and the critical theory that's developed
from it it's just so difficult to
understand unless you're willing to
dedicate months of reading to it you're
not going to get your your head round
even the basics of it
so people are sort of latching on this
idea that what we see now is cultural
Marxism in that oppressed and the
presser groups have now got more
different identity titles now we can
understand it know you really need to
get your head around
the denial of objective knowledge think
the cultural constructs the systems of
power that's the key piece of it isn't
it yeah it's the denial of the fact that
there is a truth and and the invention
of this idea that you have your truth
and I have my truth and Francis has is
true when I was the objective
but I was gonna ask you do you think
there might be a simple explanation of
why as Francis says we're having these
irrelevant conversations in this country
and that's because we're importing this
conversation wholesale from America I do
tend to think that we're that we're
doing that yet because we're seeing some
very strange race analysis which really
reflects American race relations and not
ours I heard secondhand conversation
with a black lives matter activist here
who is talking about how much more
racism black Brits suffer than Asian
South Asian Brits and this is because
this long legacy which includes the
slavery and this works in America
because America has had this
long-standing and superior whites
inferior black to it which hasn't been
resolved that they're successfully
satisfactory now but they're much more
positive about immigrants who have come
from Asia and for them so there is that
balance here we have a difference I
think where we had an influx of of
African Jamaican immigrants earlier and
then we had South Asian immigrants
coming and there was there seems to be
more hostility towards immigrants who
could be missing since then there are
two Africans who were often
Christian and I just don't think this
this analysis works I wouldn't feel
entirely confident to say I think
there's more prejudice against brown
people than black people here but it's
certainly not the same analysis as in
America so this is a direct import and
we are seeing a lot of that I disagreed
with then from a federal on Twitter who
insists that England
the UK is actually madder than America
it is a lot of the scholarship awfully
the fat activism sort of the most
influential fat activists scholars are I
here but otherwise they're almost all in
the in the US and they're sort of being
shadowed here and how much do you blame
on social media because it just seems to
me that social media exacerbates a whole
problem and what it does and especially
the internet was before you have these
couple of whack jobs who thought
whatever you know these ridiculous
theories and they'd be on their own but
on the internet you can find about a
thousand whack jobs and then you all of
a sudden you've got a community whether
they be you know fat activist in selves
or whatever else you know and did you
think it's social media's could
exacerbate it
I think exacerbates is the word some
people have said it's produced in and I
don't think it's done that but it has
it's made us more able to access all of
the madness and to react to it because
we are such reactive creatures at the
moment if we are seen insane least
examples of the left who wouldn't have
got any news or written newspaper
articles then we're having a reaction
from the reasonable right and if we see
the most and saying on the right there's
a reaction from the reasonable left and
so I don't think it's occurring to do
that the polarization of parties which
is particularly noticeable in America
that how willing people are to talk and
be friends with people from from the
other side has just really sort of
increased over about the same period
that social media
taking off perfect well listen our times
almost up to questions we'll go to our
final questions and the final question
in a second but we've had quite a
pessimistic and negative conversation
here
so I've enjoyed it yeah it goes along
with your depressive personality but is
there a way that we can find for what
we've been talking about throughout
which is the reasonable people on both
sides to come together and actually
start to produce more harmony as opposed
to a more discordant I certainly hope so
I am a little bit optimistic already I
do think that we are seeing a push back
in our and and from reasonable people
over the last few weeks I've seen a lot
of leftist academics distance themselves
from the grievant Studies approach and
we're seeing we're seeing more
willingness to regard a just ridiculous
and we're seeing obviously that this
there's also the the problems on the far
right and where we're addressing those I
think quite well so I am I I am
optimistic that people are going to get
sick of extreme irrational views and
they're just going to go to say enough
but I think it's going to probably get a
bit worse before it gets it gets better
and we can hopefully yeah it sort of
speed up this process by trying to talk
across the device ourselves and by
looking talking in terms of being
reasonable of being evidenced of being
consistently ethical rather than in
terms of those methods and those right
well that's what we try and do on the
show other than the consistently
ethically we struggling but listen the
question we always like to ask at the
end is what is the one thing that you
think we're not talking about that we
actually should be talking about I don't
think we're talking about how we know
things are true and I don't think we're
doing enough very few people consider
their FS team ology now they're just
let's got that kind of acceptance of
what is in the air so we really need to
start thinking again about how do I know
this is true what is the process there
and we need to be consistently ethical
we need to focus on the individual and
shared humanity identity caterpie's
matter certainly that is an aspect of
people but we cannot lose individuality
or common humanity for that ok well
thank you thank you very much for coming
on the show Helen like if people want to
follow you you're on Twitter at at each
clock wise and very very active there I
was following with interest where you
you get involved in you and last night I
think before you were coming here you
are involved in this massive argument
and eventually when okay I've gotta go
speak to shrieking on shoes so follow
Helen follow Helen h-block rose and
arrow magazine is at yeah perfect let's
check that out guys do you want to do
the wrap-up just to say if thank you
very much for watching the episode we
really hope you've enjoyed it please
subscribe click the bell bun which on
the things on the right of the screen
that will give you Vera
on the far right of the screen the best
site now junk that will give you
notifications if you're listening to
this on iTunes if you could leave us a
review would be insanely grateful 5
stars please and lastly if you are
enjoying it and you don't want to do any
of these things but you're more enjoying
it tweeters say something nice or tell a
friend
when I trigger polynomial social media
absolutely and it's true the put on
social media and if you didn't like it
tell someone you hate that's what you
need to do but we'll see you next week
thanks a lot guys see you soon